I got something on here all over my face
hi I'm Victoria and I'm from Edmonton
Alberta my name is Paul Lucas and I'm
Kate Lee I'm from Ottawa Ontario we are
here to taste test condiments my summer
hits when it comes to condom in hot
sauce ketchup mayo anything spicy I
don't know how well I'm gonna do I think
I could tell the difference between a
honey mustard and Dijon I'm kind of
tired I like trying new things see what
happens
let's do our friend Sarah is gonna be
grilling the chicken for us today we
didn't barbecue a lot because my dad set
the grill on fire once I'm Native
Americans so we would always have these
gigantic moose ribs
let's get moves I really can't really
good here we go all right I can't see a
thing
wait high five first we're gonna try
condiment free chicken which was the
spoon - garlic for sure I love garlic
onion powder I think it's great well
done Sarah I think I'm ready let's do
some condom mmm no it tastes better than
ketchup this is good old ketchup I feel
like she cheated
that was like cheers Cheers all right
there's mustard I think that's a Dijon
mustard
I'm still thinking like hot sauce
definitely hot sauce with Dijon no it
was mustard hot red hot but the honey
mustard dang this and FYI
that last one was trickier than I
thought sweet smoky little spicy I'm
tasting barbecue sauce and I'm tasting
some mustard I think it's like Dijon I'm
gonna go barbecue sauce in regular
mustard yes
Montreal steak spice my mom is actually
from Montreal
we had smoked me and seasonings like
that so powerful and good YUM
[Music]
I think that barbecue sauce is back i
tastes like a sweetness i tastes like
that heat wait is that what's up I think
that's wasabi did you get like Chris
penis oh my god french fried onion it is
a Dijon this time no pickle crunchy
stoppers people I like my favorite kind
of just one I'm like open anyone I did
not realize okay I'm inspired now
summers gonna be little rien no I want
to